Fest steht: Die Erde ist ein Wasserplanet
- rund drei Viertel der Erdoberfläche ist
von Ozeanen bedeckt.
Außerdem gilt Wasser als Ursprung allen Lebens
auf der Erde.
Doch noch immer nicht ist endgültig geklärt,
woher das ganze Wasser stammt.
Etwa durch die Einschläge von Kometen und
Asteroiden auf der jungen Erde?
So jedenfalls die gängige Theorie.
Doch jetzt gibt es einen neuen super-spannenden
Ansatz von einem US-Forschungsteam.
Und dabei spielt die Sonne eine entscheidende
Rolle.
Demnach könnte nämlich auch der solare Urnebel
der Ursprung des irdischen Wassers sein.
Wie das genau abgelaufen sein könnte und
warum das die Existenz von außerirdischem
Leben viel wahrscheinlicher macht, erfahrt
ihr jetzt bei Clixoom Science & Fiction, Hier
gibt es täglich spannende Science Videos,
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts herzlich willkommen!
Bisher geht man davon aus, dass wohl Asteroiden
und Kometen das irdische Wasser mitbrachten,
als sie auf die junge Erde einschlugen.
Hinweise darauf geben die chemischen Signaturen:
Die des Ozean-Wassers und des Wassers auf
Asteroiden sind sich nämlich sehr ähnlich.
Diese Theorie wird so akzeptiert, obwohl es
rätselhafte Diskrepanzen gibt.
Beispielsweise die gigantischen Wasserreservoire
im tiefen Inneren der Erde.
Das Gestein dort speichert nämlich mindestens
doppelt so viel Wasser wie in allen Weltmeeren
enthalten ist.
Und seine Signatur gleicht dem Wasser der
Asteroiden eben nicht wirklich.
Konkret geht es um den Gehalt von Deuterium:
Dieser ist im Wasser des tiefen Erdmantels
deutlich niedriger als beim Asteroiden-Wasser.
Ähnlich bei den wasserreichen Kometen, die
ebenso nicht wirklich in dieses Bild passen.
Durch die Raumsonde Rosetta nämlich konnte
man herausfinden, dass die Isotopensignatur
des Kometen-Wassers eben nicht mit der Signatur
der irdischen Ozeane übereinstimmt.
Heißt also: Eine umfassende Erklärung dafür,
was damals auf der jungen Erde geschah, kann
diese Theorie nicht liefern.
Und so tüfteln Forschungsteams weltweit ohne
Unterlass über die eine so spannende Frage:
Wie genau kam das Wasser auf die Erde?!
Ein neuer spannender Ansatz kommt jetzt von
einem Forschungsteam der Arizona State University.
Sie wollen die alte Theorie erweitern und
beziehen sich dabei auf die Sonne, genauer
gesagt auf den solaren Urnebel.
Denn dieser ist wohl das vorherrschende Reservoir
für Wasserstoff im frühen Sonnensystem gewesen,
so die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler.
Dennoch gibt es eine Diskrepanz, die sich
wieder auf den Deuterium-Gehalt bezieht.
Denn der solare Wasserstoff enthält viel
zu wenig Deuterium, um tatsächlich das Ozeanwasser
geliefert haben zu können.
Doch das US-Team hat eine Erklärung dafür.
Und die beginnt sehr früh, nämlich als die
Urerde von einem Magmaozean bedeckt war - und
zudem umgeben von einer Urwolke.
Diese zog Gase des solaren Nebels an, wodurch
sich eine erste Uratmosphäre gebildet hat,
die reich an Wasserstoff war.
Dieses band an das im Magma enthaltene Eisen,
nachdem es sich von dem glutflüssigen Gestein
gelöst hatte.
Als sich dann die Erdschichten bildeten, sank
das Eisen in den Erdkern und nahm einen Großteil
des Wasserstoffs mit.
Und jetzt aufgepasst: Die Erdkruste erstarrte
langsam und das Wasser reicherte sich in ihr
und im Erdmantel mit Deuterium an.
Bedingt dadurch, dass Deuterium eine kleinere
Affinität zu Eisen hat als normaler Wasserstoff
und dies zu einer Trennung der Isotope führte.
Auf die Erdoberfläche gelang weiteres Wasser
und zwar durch die Einschläge von Kometen
und Asteroiden - so entstanden dann Stück
für Stück die Ozeane.
Ihre neue Theorie hat das US-Forschungsteam
in Simulationen überprüft: "Wir berechneten,
wie viel Wasserstoff sich im geschmolzenen
Mantel lösen konnte und wie viel davon im
Erdkern gelandet wäre.
Dann verglichen wir diese Werte mit aktuellen
Deuterium-Anteilen aus Proben des tiefe Erdmantels."
Und tatsächlich: Auch, wenn die Urerde durch
extraterrestrische Quellen wie Asteroiden
genug Wasserstoff für sieben bis acht Ozeane
bekam, stammt eben nicht alles daraus.
Bis zu 0,5 Ozeane müssen nach Berechnungen
der Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
aus dem solaren Urnebel stammen.
Heißt also konkret: Ein bis zwei Moleküle
von 100 Molekülen irdischen Wassers stammen
demnach aus der Urwolke.
Doch dieses Urwasser hat die Erde in ihrem
Inneren vor uns versteckt: Vier bis fünf
Ozeane sind wohl im Erdkern enthalten und
das Äquivalent von rund zwei Ozeanen im tiefen
Erdmantel, so das Forschungsteam aus Arizona.
Der Rest hat dann wohl die Weltmeere gebildet.
Diese neue Theorie könnte durch Analysen
von Gestein überprüft werden.
Denn nicht nur Wasserstoff, sondern auch Edelgase,
Stickstoff und Kohlenstoff müssten in das
Erdinnere gesunken sein.
Angenommen, dass sich tatsächlich vor ewig
langer Zeit mal Gase aus dem Urnebel im irdischen
Magmaozean gelöst haben sollten.
Dazu einer der beteiligten Forscher, Jun Wu:
“Diese Gase sollten Isotopen-Spuren in der
Chemie der tiefen Gesteine hinterlassen haben,
nach denen wir nun gezielt suchen können”.
Und ihr ahnt es vielleicht schon: Diese Theorie
zum Ursprung des irdischen Wassers macht die
Existenz von Wasser auf Exoplaneten und damit
auch außerirdisches Leben noch ein Stückchen
wahrscheinlicher.
Denn nicht nur die Erde, sondern eben auch
Exoplaneten könnten auf diesem Weg zu Wasser
gekommen sein - auch ohne Asteroiden.
Dazu Wu: “Unser Modell deutet darauf hin,
dass die Bildung von Wasser fast schon zwangsweise
auf jedem ausreichend großen Gesteinsplaneten
erfolgen würde.
Ich finde das ziemlich spannend”.
Und es bestätigt immer mehr die These, dass
Leben keine Ausnahme im Weltall ist, sondern
die Regel.
Es wird also wirklich wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr lange dauern, bis wir auf solches Leben
stoßen werden.
Hier auf Clixoom erfahrt ihr es natürlich
mit als erste.
Wenn ihr kein Video dazu verpassen wollt,
dann abonniert Clixoom auch auf englisch.
Denn auch da gibt es immer wieder Videopremieren.
Dafür einfach hier draufklicken.
Und hier geht es weiter mit: Exciting Discovery:
There was no Big Bang.
Bis bald hoffentlich auch auf dem englischen
Kanal.
See you soon, stay tuned!